hoy empezamos una nueva sección y de
hecho empezamos un nuevo examen y
estamos ahora en el examen número 7 en
la sección número 2 y este es el primer
vídeo por cierto vamos a empezar el
problema número uno que está en la
página
774 el problema número uno y dice lo
siguiente cuántos elementos del conjunto
x hay en el conjunto james y déjame
ponerte aquí los dos conjuntos el
conjunto x es el conjunto que contiene
los números 30 31 30 31 32 y 33 es este
conjunto de aquí esto por una parte
previamente o al conjunto james y el
conjunto y es el conjunto de los números
a 32 33 34 35 36 32 33
34 35 y por último 36
todos estos aquí son los números que
están en el conjunto y lo que me
preguntan es cuántos elementos del
conjunto x ayer el conjunto james y
bueno si nosotros sabemos notación de
conjuntos lo que nos están preguntando
es la cardinal y that que hay de x
intersección de x intersección y 10 y
bueno recuerda que cuando nosotros
buscamos x intersección james lo que
buscamos unos elementos que se repiten
por lo tanto en este caso se repite guau
se repite el 32 el 32 se repiten y
también se repite el 33 se repite el 33
por lo tanto los elementos en este caso
en los números que se repiten entre el
conjunto x y el conjunto james es 32 y
33 y la carnalidad es la cantidad de
elementos que hay la cantidad de
elementos que hay pues son dos se
repiten dos elementos el 32 y el 33 y
esa es mi respuesta dos elementos
repetidos hay entre el conjunto x el
conjunto james y mi respuesta es el
inciso a
vamos ser el problema número dos y yo
creo que me acabe por aquí dice si
alfredo viaja diez kilómetros en dos
horas ok pensemos en alfredo en alfredo
alfredo viaja a 10 kilómetros 10
kilómetros los recordé en dos horas ok
alfredo viaja 10 kilómetros en 2 horas y
camila viaja el doble de lejos en la
mitad de ese mismo tiempo o que pasa con
camila k
y la viaja el doble de lejos es decir
que a esta distancia hay que duplicar la
o de otra manera la voy a multiplicar
por 2 viaja el doble de distancia es
decir 20 kilómetros lo recorre en la
mitad del tiempo eso quiere decir que
estas dos horas hay que dividirlas entre
2 la mitad es multiplicarlos por un
medio o sacar en la mitad lo voy a
multiplicar por un medio y me queda una
hora es decir que camila recorre 20
kilómetros en una hora guau lo que nos
preguntan es cuál es la velocidad
promedio a la que viaja camila y bueno
esto ya está muy fácil recuerda que la
velocidad es igual a la distancia entre
el tiempo lo cual es a 20 kilómetros
entre una hora lo cual es 20 kilómetros
por hora y es el inciso ser otro
problema que estaba bastante sencillo
y bueno voy a borrar la pantalla aunque
recuerda que tal vez tú te equivoques al
principio pero no te preocupes no te
desesperes no te pongas triste el chiste
es practicar problema número 3 y muchas
veces los problemas solamente tienen que
ver con que tú sepas leer el problema de
manera adecuada eso es muy importante el
consejo que te doy es que conserven la
calma y leas el problema de manera
adecuada así vas a poder darte cuenta de
en qué consiste el problema y así lo
podrás solucionar entonces es muy
importante leer el problema de manera
adecuada muchas veces ahí está la
solución pero en fin vamos a ver el
problema número 3 y jobs mi sobrina
marco este problema con plumón negro
espero realmente espero que esté viendo
lo que ustedes están viendo a ver dice x
x es igual y es que mi sobrina presentó
este examen en sexto grado en eeuu
veamos dice x es igual a acá por acá - 2
espero que ustedes estén viendo en lo
mismo
cada porque a menos 2 y lo que me
preguntan es cuánto vale x 1 no es así
cuánto vale x + 1 es lo que me preguntan
bueno si fuera así el problema pues no
hay de qué preocuparse lo único que hay
que hacer es sumar uno de ambos lado
esta ecuación voy a sumar uno justo por
acá y uno por acá de tal manera que me
queda que x uno es lo mismo que camps
que multiplica acá menos dos y esto más
uno pero esta parte de aquí la podemos
distribuir esto es lo mismo que cada por
acá y acá por menos dos y me quedaría
está cuadrada menos 2 camps y por último
este 1 más 1 y bueno este de aquí este
de aquí lo que sí quiero que veas de una
manera rápida eso mismo que un trinomio
es guardado perfecto esto es lo mismo
que acá menos 1 elevado al cuadrado 4
del primero menos dos veces el primero
por el segundo más del segundo y en mis
respuestas no está al menos 1 al
cuadrado o no no no pero si está
cuadrada menos dos más uno está justo en
esta parte de aquí entonces vamos a
quedarnos con esta parte de aquí esa va
a ser mi respuesta y es el inciso c ya
está problema número 4
hoy tenemos una gráfica tenemos a un
tecnócratas ya no vamos a ponerlo justo
aquí esta va a ser mía que dry es aquí
tengo mi eje x vamos a poner quién es
quién éste es mi hija jane este es mi
eje x y tenemos una recta esta recta que
pasa justo por aquí tengo esta recta y
nos dicen que esta recta pasa por este
punto que es el punto cero coma
10.1 ok y me dicen si esta recta tiene
como ecuación y es igual aa x + b cuál
es la gráfica que mejor representa a la
función amplio que quiero saber es la
gráfica que mejor representa la función
que es igual a dos veces a por x
de más
bueno lo primero que quiero que te des
cuenta es que tienen la misma ordenada
de origen y además sabemos que en esta
gráfica de ordenada el origen es 1 y es
1 porque es justo en donde interceptamos
al eje de las 10 b vale 1 es decir que
esta gráfica y esta gráfica van a pasar
ambas por el mismo punto van a pasar las
dos por este punto de aquí el punto 0 1
lo segundo que quiero que te des cuenta
es que sea cual sea la pendiente de esta
recta de amarillo la gráfica que
nosotros estamos buscando debe de tener
el doble de pendiente y recuerda que
tener el doble pendiente es decir el
doble de rápido dicho de otra manera va
a estar más inclinada así que a no puedo
sacar de aquí la pendiente pero más o
menos puedo tener una idea de cómo se va
a ver la gráfica de ye igual a 2 x + b
se va a ver algo más o menos así el
doble
inclinada por lo tanto más o menos así
se tiene que ver mi respuesta ok vamos a
fijar los incisos y si te das cuenta
todos los incisos no cortan al eje de
las 10 en el punto cero menos uno
excepto el inciso b y el inciso c pero b
es más pronunciada b es más pronunciada
que el inciso c de hecho es enciso c se
ve una gráfica que tiene una recta menos
pronunciada que la recta original e
iguala a x + b el inciso sem se ve más o
menos así tengo una recta que va por acá
más o menos así entonces éste sería un
inciso c este de aquí es mi inciso b y
entonces la respuesta se le sube porque
es una gráfica de una recta que tiene
una pendiente más pronunciada bueno ya
está el problema número cuatro vamos a
borrar todo esto de aquí y vamos a hacer
el problema número 5 que consiste en
dibujar unos ciertos triángulos así que
vamos a dibujar este triángulo
es un triángulo rectángulo algo así
así ok y así ok tenemos un triángulo que
es rectángulo y no sólo eso me dicen que
este este lado mide x este lado también
mide x por lo tanto es un triángulo
rectángulo que además de ser rectángulo
es un triángulo isósceles y de la manera
muy rápida podemos decir que este ángulo
vale 45 grados 10 de aquí también vale
45 grados ok y además me dicen que el
perímetro el perímetro de este triángulo
rectángulo es cuatro más dos veces la
raíz de dos ok muy bien hasta ahí y lo
que me preguntan es cuál es el valor de
x ok y lo primero que quiero que veas es
que nosotros podemos obtener de manera
muy rápida este lado este lado
utilizando el teorema de pitágoras esta
hipotenusa y la hipotenusa es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de uno de los catetos
elevado al cuadrado de x cuadrada más el
otro cateto elevado al cuadrado más x
cuadrado que por cierto esto es lo mismo
que la raíz cuadrada de 2 veces x
cuadrada x cuadrada + x cuadrada es 2
veces x cuadrada y aquí puedo dividir la
raíz esto es lo mismo que la raíz de dos
por la raíz de x cuadrada de tal manera
que esta raíz y este cuadrado se van y
me queda que en este lado la hipotenusa
es lo mismo que x por la raíz de 2 esto
es lo que mide este lado la hipotenusa
la hipotenusa mide x más la raíz la
hipotenusa mide x raíz de 2 y bueno esto
tiene toda la lógica del mundo porque de
hecho al principio de de este examen en
la pagina 774 nos dicen si tenemos un
triángulo de la forma 90° 45 grados 45
grados y si uno de sus lados tiene un
valor de x entonces la hipotenusa vale x
raíz de 2 pudimos haber utilizado ese
tipo o ese consejo que nos daba en la
pagina 774 o bien también lo podemos
calcular de una manera matemática
utilizando el problema de pitágoras
si yo quiero el perímetro es de
triángulo rectángulo quién es el
perímetro de este triángulo bueno pues
el perímetro es el mismo que x más x mas
x raíz de 2 lo que estoy haciendo
sumando cada uno de sus lados y para
esto es exactamente lo mismo que 2 x mas
x raíz de 2 ok pero esto esto tiene que
ser igual a lo que nos dicen aquí a la
derecha esto debe ser igual a 4 más dos
veces la raíz de 2 y de aquí de una
manera muy rápida ya podrías asociar x
con un cierto valor x tiene que ser que
está al lado de la raíz de 2 lo cual es
2x tiene que ser 2 para que se cumpla
esta igualdad 2 por 2 es 4 + 2 raíz de 2
ahora si no no ves una manera muy clara
justo aquí puedes factorizar la equis y
decir que esto es x que multiplica a 2 +
raíz de 2 y esto va a ser igual a 4 + 2
price de 2 y de aquí pasar esto
dividiendo y factorizar aquí un 2 y vas
a llegar a que x es igual a 2 justo a lo
mismo y por cierto la respuesta de este
problema es el inciso a lo único que
tenemos que hacer este problema son dos
cosas la primera a sacar la hipotenusa
es muy importante para calcular el
perímetro y la segunda es asociar a x
con este valor de 2 muy bien problema
número 5 problema número 6 pero el
problema número 6 de una tabla la cual
para hacer todo esto mucho más rápido ya
trabaje antes de empezar el vídeo
entonces aquí tengo esta tabla muy bien
y ahorita vamos a ver a qué se refiere
esta tabla dice las calificaciones del
examen de historia
de historia que se realizó el martes a
16 alumnos del salón se muestran en la
tabla siguiente es decir uno de estos
alumnos de los 16 alumnos del salón sacó
100 % sacó 100 puntos 2 sacaron 95 490
185 3 estudiantes sacaron 80 puntos 275
270 0 65 y solamente 11 saco 60 nadie
reprobó vamos bien hasta aquí bernardo
fue el único alumno que estuvo ausente
ese martes
verdad los enfermos o faltó ese día qué
sé yo sin embargo se le aplicó el examen
a la semana siguiente yo obtuvo una
calificación de 95 bien por verdad no
creo que no le fue tan mal sea con 95
puntos bernardo que fue el único alumno
que estuvo ausente el martes del examen
si contamos la calificación de bernardo
cuál es la mediana de las calificaciones
del examen ok aquí tengo 16 alumnos
calificaciones de esos 16 alumnos pero
es lo que nos hace falta es cuánto saco
bernardo bernardo con 95 puntos eso
quiere decir que en lugar de tener dos
estudiantes que sacaron 95 puntos vamos
a tener tres estudiantes que sacaron 95
puntos ya contando a bernardo ya con
esto estamos contando a bernardo y
estamos contando que en el salón en
total hay 17 alumnos bernardo sacó 95
puntos y entonces en lugar de tener 2
estudiantes en un principio que sacaron
95 puntos ahora tenemos 3 contando a
bernardo así que lo que queremos es la
mediana y la mediana pues es el número
que está justo en medio así que para no
complicarnos la vida que está si ponemos
todos los datos entonces vamos a
acomodar los datos y vamos a ponerlos
aquí tengo un alumno que sacó 100 puntos
tengo 3 que se acaban 95 entonces 95
a
95-95 3 alumnos de 95 puntos 40 90 90 90
90 y 90 después uno sacó 85 85
380 80 80
82 75 y 2 70 75
75 70 70 y después uno sacó 61 sacos 60
ok ya tengo aquí mis a 17 datos vamos a
ver si 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 17 perfecto ya tengo 17 datos aquí
y mi mediana es el valor que está justo
en medio así que voy a contar 8 para
abajo 8 para arriba y el que esté justo
en medio va a ser mi mediana
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y para camps 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 y ya está se nota el luego luego que
un mediana que es el valor que está
justo en medio es 85 no sea bien cuál
había sido la mediana antes de contar la
calificación de bernando creo que parece
ser que también fue de 85 no importa lo
que sí sé es que la mediana en este caso
que es justo lo que me piden es 85 que
es el valor que está justo en medio y
por cierto 85 es el inciso c
ya está aquí tenemos la respuesta del
problema número 6